tengamos un breve resumen de lo que es
una función antes de que hablemos de lo
que es el dominio de una función y de
hecho lo podemos ver de la siguiente
forma pensemos que a lo mejor nuestra
función está no sé representado por una
caja y en esta caja nosotros podemos
meter algunas entradas algunos valores
de entrada lo que va a hacer esta caja
es producir nos algunos valores de
salida verdad o alguna regla de cómo es
que va a trabajar con esa con esas
entradas y nos va a producir algún
resultado
por ejemplo veamos el siguiente ejemplo
qué tal que tenemos la función f x igual
a 2 entre x muy bien entonces vamos a
ver qué pasaría con un ejemplo
particular digamos que aquí tenemos
nuestra caja que representa la función f
y nosotros le introducimos el valor de 3
este es el valor digamos de entrada esto
por supuesto nos produce un valor de
salida que sería efe de 3 verdad
así que cuánto vale efe de 3 sería aquí
nos dice justamente cómo operar con el
valor 3 nos dice a 3 tiene que dividir
al número 2 verdad el número 3 tienen
que dividir al número 2 entonces el
valor de salida sería 2 entre 3 verdad y
podríamos pensar no sé cualquier otro
valor raro por ejemplo podríamos poner
el valor que no se podríamos poner aquí
el valor pi que va a entrar a nuestra
caja a nuestra caja de la función f y el
resultado tendría que ser fdp verdad
pero quién sería fdp
efe de pis sería simplemente tomar 2 y
dividirlo entre pi
eso sería nuestro valor de salida ahora
vamos a intentar algo más interesante
qué pasaría si en nuestra caja
efe le intentamos dar el valor 0 muy
bien entonces según nuestra regla que
tenemos aquí al valor 0 tendríamos que
operarlo de la siguiente forma
tendríamos
tener dos y dividirlo entre cero sin
embargo esta es una expresión matemática
que no está definida verdad no está
definida y por lo tanto no podemos decir
cuál es el valor que nos arroja verdad
así que en realidad en realidad el valor
cero no tiene una un valor de salida ha
definido verdad está indefinido así que
esto es lo que nos da la idea de que es
un dominio de una función el dominio es
el conjunto de todas las digamos de
todos los valores de entrada o de todas
las entradas para los que la función
está definida por ejemplo en este caso
la función está definido para cualquier
número real excepto una verdad excepto
el cero porque todos los números los
podemos dividir excepto por el mismo no
podemos dividir entre el número cero
verdad es lo que ocurre vamos a escribir
eso
el dominio de una función
dominio de un
función y justo lo que dije hace unos
momentos es el es el conjunto es el
conjunto de todas las entradas de todas
las entradas o de todos los valores de
entrada vamos a escribirlo así de todas
las entradas sobre las que digamos sobre
las sobre las que la función tiene
salidas definidas sobre las que la
función tiene salidas definidas tiene
salidas
definidas
definidas muy bien por ejemplo en el
caso que teníamos anteriormente no
teníamos una salida definida para el
valor cero verdad por lo tanto el cero
no está en el dominio de esta función
muy bien así que esto lo podríamos
incluso escribir verdad el dominio de
esta función que que trabajamos con
color rosa el dominio es un conjunto
verdad y usamos el digamos esta
expresión matemática que es una llave es
una llave para representar un conjunto
verdad es el conjunto de todos los equis
que son elementos este símbolo significa
que x es un elemento de qué conjunto
pues el conjunto de los números reales y
así es como denotamos a los números
reales como una r mayúscula con una
barrita aquí verdad sería como una r y
le ponemos una barrita extra del lado
izquierdo entonces tenemos que ponerle
restricciones a estos como a este
conjunto verdad no sólo son todos los
reales sino que además esos valores
tienen que ser
de cero no pueden ser cero porque el
cero no tiene una salida definida verdad
entonces por ejemplo podríamos intentar
no se ha definido otra función vamos
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo hagamos otro
ejemplo justamente para que sea mucho
más claro qué pasa si nosotros tenemos
la función g de iu y además no no
siempre tiene que ser
efe si x verdad puede ser que la función
y los valores de entrada lo
representamos con la letra i y digamos
que g de iu es la raíz cuadrada de ye
menos seis muy bien entonces nosotros
tenemos nuevamente nuestra
representación de la cajita que tiene a
la función g y vamos a introducir
valores de entrada que van a ser yes
verdad y esto nos produce una salida que
es gd y muy bien entonces nos
preguntamos cuál es el dominio de esta
función y la función si nos damos cuenta
bueno está definido por una raíz
cuadrada este operador matemático que
representa la raíz cuadrada y de hecho
es es la raíz principal verdad podríamos
tomar positivo o negativo pero cuando no
lo indicamos es positivo sin embargo
para poder tomar la raíz la raíz
cuadrada de un número este número tiene
que ser mayor o igual que 0 verdad no lo
podemos encontrar raíces de números
negativos así que necesitamos que esta
expresión que tenemos dentro de -6 sea
mayor o igual que 0 entonces menos 6
tiene que ser mayor o igual que 0 o si
sumamos 6 de ambos lados que tiene que
ser mayor o igual que 6 verdad entonces
esto me está diciendo que el dominio de
la función que es el conjunto de todos
los valores reales los yes que son
números reales tales que tales que ya es
mayor o igual que 6 verdad entonces este
es el dominio de la
y espero que esto empiece a cobrar
sentido esto es digamos una todos estos
dos ejemplos que hemos puesto son formas
clásicas de cómo están definidas las
funciones pero también puede tomar
formas mucho más exóticas por ejemplo
qué pasaría si si si definimos la
siguiente función digamos qué hdx pueda
tomar dos valores digamos que sea 1 si x
es igual a no sea pi o 0
si nos x es igual a 3 y h es nuestra
función y lo que tiene ahora es una
expresión mucho más rara verdad así que
te invito a que pienses cuál es el
dominio trata de hacerlo tú solo ahora
sí si nos damos cuenta sólo hay dos
valores de entrada verdad sólo podríamos
tomar el valor [ __ ] [ __ ] verdad y el valor
de hdmi quizás deberías
mejor pi pi cuál es el valor que toma la
función al introducir pi como entrada
bueno nos dice que si si la entrada es
para entonces la función vale 1 y por
ejemplo si h
si evaluamos h en el valor de entrada 3
esto nos dice que si la entrada es 3 el
valor de h es 0 muy bien y esto nos dice
que por ejemplo si nosotros intentamos
evaluar h en 4 bueno pues en realidad
aquí no nos dicen nada de cómo operar
con el valor de entrada 4 verdad
entonces esto está indefinido 4 no
pertenece al dominio de la función
entonces con esto concluimos que el
dominio de esta función h
el conjunto que tiene dos elementos de
verdad tiene al tres y tiene a pi son
los únicos elementos de este dominio son
los únicos valores sobre los que está
definida la función así que espero esto
te te deum un sabor de por qué es
importante conocer el dominio de una
función no todas las funciones están
definidas sobre todos los números reales
algunos por ejemplo estarán definidos
sobre un conjunto pequeño como esta
función o quizás estén solo definidos
sobre los números naturales o sobre los
números enteros quizás sólo estén
definidos para los números negativos o
quizás tengan algunas excepciones y
bueno todo esto lo seguiremos viendo a
medida que veamos más y más ejemplos